some of the most iconic characters in
star wars history have been of
mandalorian ancestry but one of the
biggest questions people seem to have is
who's the best mandalorian denjarian or
boba fett welcome back everyone i'm
rocket riley and since they now both
have their own series on disney plus i'm
here to help answer the question of who
is the better man delorean between boba
fett and denjarin the first thing we'll
be comparing the two on is their armor
best car armor is one of the most
important symbols of mandalorian culture
typically featuring an easily
recognizable mandalorian helmet this
armor is made from best car a rare metal
which is able to withstand blaster bolts
and even lightsabers the question though
is who has the better armor denjarin or
boba fett
then jaren had his original armor
destroyed after an intense battle with a
mudhorn and received new best car armor
as their award for bounty this shiny new
armor sets den apart from the rest of
the bounty hunters and has a very high
level of structural integrity boba fett
however has some of the most iconic
mandalorian armor of all time ever since
his appearance in the empire strikes
back fans have admired his unique green
armor featuring a distinctive dent in
the helmet this armor was even able to
protect boba from the acid in the
sarlacc stomach since boba's armor has a
more unique look and a long history
going all the way back to its original
owner and boba's father jango fett boba
fett beats out denjarin on who has the
best armor while denjarn likely has more
protective armor boafetz simply has a
better story and is more recognizable as
a star wars icon the next item to
discuss is the two mandalorians
hand-to-hand combat abilities
mandalorians are typically trained from
a young age in melee combat and these
two are no different boba fett was
raised by legendary bounty hunter jango
fett and dinjarin was raised as a
foundling by the children of the watch
both of which helped form them into
formidable fighters we've seen much of
denjaran's capabilities in hand-to-hand
combat but he relies heavily upon his
weapons and gadgets boba fett however
has shown his melee strength on multiple
occasions although he was easily knocked
into the sarlacc pit by a blind man boba
fett is one of the most impressive
fighters in the star wars galaxy likely
due to his training with the tuscans
because of this training he's able to
take down large groups of enemies with
melee attacks only it's this training
with the tuscans i believe which puts
boba in the lead for this category the
next category to compare the two on is
their weapon abilities both din jarn and
boba fett have a large arsenal of
weapons on them at all times including a
series of blades blasters grappling
cords and wrist flame throwers weapons
unique to boba fett include a backpack
rocket and knee pad rocket darts weapons
unique to denjarin include the whistling
birds and the ambient phase pulse rifle
while both feature their own unique
weaponry din jarns are better simply due
to the fact that they're able to take
down many specific individuals in a
group and also completely disintegrate
his enemies these weapons and his skill
in using them puts dinjarn in the lead
for this category the next item to
discuss is the two mandalorian sidekicks
for this category we'll be pitting din
jaren's child figure grogu against boba
fett's partner fenik shand din jarn
rescued grogu in the first season of the
mandalorian and this child has become
one of the most beloved star wars
characters of all time fenik shand on
the other hand was rescued by boba fett
in the first season of the mandalorian
as well but she has yet to become a star
wars icon like grogu while fenik shand
has strong combat abilities grogu's
likability and force sensitivity put him
and din jarn in the lead for this
category the next category we'll be
discussing is each character's power
symbol boafet's symbol of power is his
place as daimyo of mos espa on the
throne of the late job of the hut this
throne however has been somewhat
discredited by the other hutts as well
as by the pikes who have begun
controlling more of tatooine's
territories denjarin's symbol of power
is the darksaber which he won in combat
from maf gideon the darksaber is the
symbol of leadership for the entirety of
the mandalorian people and it was built
by tar vizla the first person to be both
mandalorian and a jedi this darkseber is
one of the coolest symbols of power in
the star wars galaxy one of the most
recognizable lightsabers of all time
it's for these reasons that denjarin
wins in this category now let's discuss
the two individuals character arcs boba
fett has been somewhat inconsistent in
his character development we saw him as
a child on the prequels and in the clone
wars series as well as shortly in the
original trilogy he didn't seem to
develop much from his original character
until his time in the sarlacc pit and
then with the tuscans but then he seemed
to completely change as a character with
little screen time to see that character
growth he changed from a merciless
bounty hunter to a forgiving and
welcoming leader seemingly on a dime
then jaren on the other hand has had
plenty of time to show his growth at the
beginning of the first season of the
mandalorian we saw a ruthless bounty
hunter who adhered strictly to the way
of the mandalore by the end of the
second season however den had become a
somewhat open-minded father figure to
the child grogu it's for this reason
that dinjaran most certainly has a
better character arc than boba fett for
the next section i'd like to compare
instances for each character when they
were at their most resourceful for
denjarin i'd argue that the time he was
most resourceful was when he took down
moff gideon's tie fighter using his
jetpack and wrist grappling cord din
flies over the tie fighter grapples the
wing of the ship and places a bomb on
the wing for boba fett i believe the
time he was most resourceful was when he
escaped from the sarlacc pit boba uses
the oxygen from a nearby stormtrooper to
give himself some air to breathe then
uses that oxygen as fuel for his wrist
flamethrower which he uses to escape i'd
argue that in this case bobo was more
resourceful relying not just on his own
gadgets but also using his surroundings
to his advantage
for the final category let's compare the
two characters motivations
in the book of boba fett series it isn't
quite clear what boba fett's motivations
are we know his goal is to lead from
jabba's palace with respect rather than
with fear but we haven't truly been
given a reason as to why he wants to do
this denjaran on the other hand has a
very strong motivation in his series his
goal is to protect the child grogu and
return him to his own kind the jedi he
has a strong motivation to protect grogu
because he sees him basically as his own
son and he would put protecting grogo
above all else including his own life
it's for this reason that denjarin has a
stronger character motivation than boba
fett that brings the final score to boba
fett with three and din jarn with five
so i'd argue that din jaren is
ultimately the best mandalorian and he's
become one of the most iconic star wars
characters ever in a very short amount
of time for a complete rundown of
everything we know so far about another
iconic star wars character series check
out this video on the upcoming obi-wan
kenobi series also don't forget to
subscribe like this video and thanks for
watching rocky riley